[Music]
[Applause]
all right let me explain you don't know
this is a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show so far
hundreds and hundreds of challengers not
one winner no one's found us making
mistake why we're infallible I think yes
yeah we're gods who don't make mistakes
well tonight two fans named Jamie and
Bryan think they have caught a mistake
they claim it happened during a segment
where Josh GAD and I were getting ready
to recreate a scene from the movie The
Goonies hey Conan this is Jamie and Ryan
and we wanted to point out mistake that
you made yeah yeah during the episode
with Josh GAD he wanted to reenact a
scene for one of his favorite movies The
Goonies
now you pointed out that everyone knows
the Goonies movies because it's 70 years
old
this is the scene towards the end of the
movie this is where you towards the end
of the movie I don't want to give
anything away but essentially the
Goonies it's been around for 70 years
actually it's not it's only 28 years old
came out in 1985 I should know that's
when I was born and I don't think I'm 70
years old
sorry Conan we got you we got you
[Music]
wait gotcha um but Jamie and Bryan I'm
saying you seem like a nice couple I
gotta tell you though I have seen more
relaxed smiles in a hostage video they
met at the ladies section of the lens
crafter two for one he looks like he
just saw his goatee for the first time
[Applause]
I'm sorry guys but you are dead dead
wrong yes yes The Goonies came out in
1985 but that was actually a remake the
original Goonies the original Goonies
film was released in 1943 at the height
of World War two the film the film's
bent out of pratical why did they find
your cinema knowledge so hilarious stop
laughing
it came out in 1943 at the height of
World War two the films been out of
print for almost 70 years but luckily it
was restored and it was just rerelease
on DVD last week I happen to have one of
the only copies Oh some skepticism let's
watch a scene now from the original 1943
version of The Goonies
[Music]
well see your game according to this map
the treasure should be no more than a
hop skip and a jump away
jeepers gone holy cow what is it most
honorable chump
gold-silver so data somebody even more
precious more bond that's right I'm slop
see our war bonds or won't give you a
off the bump
we Goonies are fighting for freedom me
too I just enlisted in the army because
we're all in this together
except you [ __ ]
[Applause]
quickly crash alright
well I guess we've proven our point
again apology accepted from sceptical
crowd and the challenged toodles fans if
you think you've spotted an era on our
show
reported at team koco.com / haha I found
it error we will sort it out right here
on the air let's see if you've got what
it takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro